bonjour je m'appelle denis villeneuve je suis
le réalisateur de Blade Runner 2049 j'ai
décidé de demander à un couple d'artistes que
je respecte de créer trois nouvelles
qui dramatisent certains événements clés qui se
sont produits après 2019 lorsque le premier Blade
Runner a lieu
mais avant 2049  quand ma nouvelle
histoire de Blade Runner commence, mon ami Luke Scott a
réalisé ce court métrage que vous êtes sur le point de
voir. J'espère que vous avez apprécié cet
aperçu spécial du monde de Blade Runner
2048.
dur
[Musique]
IVA es-tu bon
où est ta mère alors mère
alors qu'est-ce que tu m'as apporté cette fois j'ai
le pouvoir et la gloire
très excitée elle peut t'emmener
c'est à propos d'une prêtresse hors la loi dont
elle essaie de comprendre le sens
d'être lui ce n'est pas triste c'est l'
un de mes favoris tout ça je vous verrai la
prochaine fois
bon travail souper monsieur
3000 3000 les couvertures à peine mon voisin
parle à 3000 je le pousse déjà
allez un jour tu as acheté mon  blocs
avant faible Imperius riche en nutriments du
meilleur tu ne m'auras pas sans
intuition allez
4 000 n'aime pas mon offre
regarde et essaie ailleurs toujours
plaisir de traiter avec toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais je suis sur le point d'être Je pense que j'ai
trouvé un travail dans un État voyou que vous cherchez peut-être
J'ai l'adresse Je vous verrai
plus tard
quand j'ai vu Blade Runner pour la première fois J'avais fini
La vision de Ridley Scott a touché tellement d'
accords  J'ai pu immédiatement reconnaître son
impact sur l'ensemble du monde cinématographique maintenant que
j'ai eu l'incroyable
opportunité de continuer l'histoire et de
réaliser Blade Runner 2049 qui reprend
30 ans après le premier film, donc
dans cet esprit, j'ai décidé de demander à
quelques artistes  que je respecte pour créer
trois nouvelles qui dramatisent certains
événements clés survenus après 2019 lorsque
le premier Blade Runner a lieu mais
avant 2040 9 lorsque ma nouvelle
histoire de Blade Runner commence, mon ami Luke Scott a
réalisé ce court métrage tu es ab  à
voir J'espère que vous avez apprécié cet
aperçu spécial dans le monde de Blade Runner
2036 nos roulements de mémoire depuis le moment où
ils sont tous endommagés dans la panne d'électricité mais
il y a parfois des fragments
[Applaudissements]
pas de session de conclusion
23h17  juste beaucoup de la fin de
Wallace aux secteurs de magistrat l1 ou
9 à 26 et ainsi de suite
terminé MD merci pour votre patience je
n'avais pas l'intention de vous faire attendre le
particulier zuv mon affliction rend un
peu difficile
mr.  Wallace, nous vous avons accordé cette
réunion par déférence pour vos
contributions,
vous savez depuis la contribution, nous avons
reconnu que pour le bien public pour
leur santé,
vous vous souvenez de la faim, alors vous vous livrez au
reclus dont les brevets maintiennent cette faim
à distance.
Je crois en la vie
en fait, j'ai  chassez plus de vie de notre
terre que jamais auparavant, mais c'est en train de mourir
vous êtes en train de mourir, ce qui nous amène à
notre préoccupation actuelle.
nous tous qui avons été perdus dans la
panne d'électricité cette coupure de l'histoire est morte
plus l'
humanité n'a survécu aussi longtemps qu'en
écrasant la terre pour répondre à ses besoins les
étoiles notre seul espoir sont cachés derrière
les vies que vous ne me permettrez pas de
créer bien les colonies sont  prospérer
insuffisant pour les besoins de la
survie ultime vos lois ont changé les
mains du progrès les lois empêchent le sang de couler dans
les rues la
phase de Nexus n'est pas fiable les garanties mises en place
mis en place par Tyrell avec négligence pour
beaucoup sont morts nous n'ajouterons pas à ce
nombre par des réplicants vivront aussi longtemps
ou aussi peu qu'un client paiera mes
réplicants ne seront jamais adultes ils
ne courront jamais
ils obéissent simplement avancent trouver une
arme à cela  maintenant qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
un ange et je lui ai fait lever les yeux vers la
gauche révéler
que vous commettez un crime Wallace c'est
assez
soulever le dieu de verre non non non non c'est
mal
ça fait mal oui tu dois faire un choix
ta vie ou  le mien comprends-tu oui
fais ça maintenant c'est mal